the cool thing about recruitment is it
doesn't really matter what background
what education or anything you have it's
not based on that at all so you look at
half the office here you have people
with meteorology degrees law degrees
philosophy degrees all great recruiters
but look at their resumes you're like
they don't match at all they're
completely different people so it does
as you say come completely down to
characteristics and for me number one i
look for is resilience so i always need
some form of example from someone of a
time that they failed and it can be
small it can be huge but i think what's
really important coming into this job is
having some muscle memory of failure and
then what came after that so what
lessons you learned how you changed the
way you did something because you and i
both know this job is all about failing
every single day learning from it doing
it again not giving up so i think an
example of this is something i look for
in every grad interview that i do if
someone says i've never failed one i
don't believe them but two they're gonna
have a pretty hard ride joining this
type of a career because you start
knowing nothing and the only way you
really progress is by doing it wrong
being told hey change this up and then
just learning by doing so i think
resilience is key i think number two is
emotional intelligence so this job's all
about speaking to people connecting
people if you don't like speaking to
people or talking to different people
understanding one person is very
different from the next so you've got to
sell in a slightly different way or talk
to them in a slightly different way
you're going to struggle with this job
and i think recruitment is slowly like
morphing into more of an email writing
type thing rather than when i started
where it was just like pound the phone
get on the phone just call switchboards
i think now in the techy age or app it's
harder to pound switchboards where most
your clients might not even have a
switchboard so i think maybe it's less
important just by selling with your
words but also now on on email but i
think emotional intelligence knowing
your audience is also key those are the
two main ones i think i actually look
for outside of the are you competitive
like this is a sales job this is not hr
this is not a form of other consulting
this is sales you have to want to be
number one hate being number two but
also do you understand that working
together is key to building a business
and for us especially we can't have a
bunch of sales people who just want to
be number one and not help the wider
course we have to have people that buy
into the vision that want to help each
other and grow the company because they
know if they do that they'll be more
successful for it i think those are the
things i look for but apart from that
it's a really cool career where to be
honest it doesn't matter what the resume
or tv says it's purely based on the
personality interview when i speak to
them like i'm never gonna know if
someone's gonna be a good recruiter
they're just looking at their
backgrounds which is why i love this
sort of thing i get to work with
different people from different
backgrounds who all bring different
characteristics but i think yeah
resilience and emotional intelligence
are the key things i look for
[Music]